logischerweise ist das auch bei uns das
thema und ich freue mich dass heute
morgen bei uns sind sieben tage lang die
obfrau der linksfraktion im auswärtigen
ausschuss und sprecherin für
internationale politik und abrüstung
guten morgen ihn und michael roth ist
bei uns aus der spd fraktion
vorsitzender auch im auswärtigen
ausschuss wir werden ganz viele nach
vorne gucken in diesem gespräch so viel
zeit wie wir haben aber einen kleinen
blick zurück würde ich dann trotzdem
noch machen wir haben drei wochen jetzt
krieg in der ukraine welche entscheidung
beziehungsweise fehleinschätzungen aus
den vergangenen jahren ist in diesem
zusammenhang aus ihrer sicht herr roth
die schmerzhafteste sie waren auch acht
jahre staatsminister im auswärtigen amt
dass bei aller notwendigen
dialogbereitschaft gelegentlich die
wehrhaftigkeit und die stärke auf der
strecke geblieben ist wir haben immer
wieder gehofft dass ein autoritärer
herrscher wie putin auch bereit ist auf
gute vernünftige argumente einzugehen
und sich auch er dem frieden
verpflichtet fühlt aber wir hätten
sicherlich noch selbstbewusster und
stärker auftreten müssen um deutlich zu
machen dass eben eine verständigung die
nichts mit frieden und versöhnung zu tun
hat für uns inakzeptabel ist ein vorteil
denn die linke hatte eine besondere
beziehung zu russland auf eine besondere
beziehung zu bleiben hier putin die
aufgabe welcher selbstgewissheit war für
sie in den vergangenen 21 tagen die
schmerzhafteste muss sie korrigieren wir
haben keine beziehung zur russischen
regierung wir haben immer mit der
opposition einen kontakte pflegt mit den
oppositionsparteien
wir haben allerdings uns absolut geirrt
und getäuscht
wir dachten wir haben mit präsident
putin in russland einen präsidenten der
rational denkt der weiß dass ein krieg
in der ukraine vielleicht militärisch
für eine solche überlegene nuklearmacht
gewinnbar ist aber politisch ist sie auf
keinen fall zu gewinnen und wir haben
uns darin getäuscht wir dachten nicht
dass er tatsächlich zu einem solchen
krieg zu einem angriffskrieg der
völkerrechtswidrig ist der durch nichts
zu rechtfertigen ist fähig ist das war
eine täuschung da sind wir leider nicht
alleine trotzdem aber muss ich sagen es
ist nicht falsch gewesen was die
entspannungs politik von willy brandt
und egon bahr uns gebracht haben nämlich
die wiedervereinigung und vieles mehr
insofern würde ich davor warnen jetzt
alles auf den müllhaufen der geschichte
zu werfen und zu denken das war alles
falsch ganz im gegenteil will ja auch
gar keiner also insofern herr roth die
rede von wolodimir zielinsky wenn die
schalte funktioniert technisch waren wir
jetzt mal entspannt ausgehen auf die
harte kritik an der bundesregierung an
deutschland und damit auch in der
koalition erwarten sie
die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer sind
weiter in einem ganz furchtbaren
angriffskrieg ausgesetzt und putin hat
keinen zweifel daran gelassen dass er
mit aller härte und brutalität weiter
zuschlagen wird insofern kann ich mir
schon vorstellen das ist eine klare
erwartungshaltung auch unsere
ukrainischen freundinnen und freunde
gibt noch mehr zu tun militärisch mehr
zu tun mehr zu tun bei der humanitären
hilfe und die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
bei ihrer mutigen und tapferen kampf
gegen diesen furchtbaren krieg zu
unterstützen das vermuten viele
beobachter dass seelands die
möglicherweise auch mehr militärische
unterstützung erwartet was würden sie
ihm sagen in diesem zusammenhang wenn
sie ihm direkt gegenüberstehen würden
womit der rechnen kann aus deutschland
und sollte nun wir haben ja den auftritt
von hansi lenski gestern im us-kongress
gesehen wo er auch eine flugverbotszone
der nato gefordert hat ich halte es für
richtig dass bundeskanzler scholz diesen
wahnsinn zurückgewiesen hat und ich
hoffe dass das auch so bleibt eine
flugverbotszone der nato in der ukraine
gegen russland ist nichts anderes als
eine kriegserklärung an russland und
würde mit einem dritten weltkrieg
bringen und ich glaube jetzt ist
wirklich bei aller kritik die das
stattfindet also das leid was da jeden
tag passiert und dass menschen dort
sterben jeden tag müssen wir besonnen
sein dass der krieg nicht eskaliert zu
einem krieg zwischen nato und russland
weil das würde tatsächlich ein inferno
ein schlachtfeld europa bedeuten und das
kann niemand wollen ich verstehe dass
die republikaner vor allem gegen die
trump anhänger jetzt gerade diese
flugverbotszone wollen aber ich finde
deutschland muss hier vor allen dingen
in verantwortung der deutschen
bevölkerung in der bevölkerung in europa
alles unterlassen was in einem dritten
weltkrieg münden kann da sind sie
vermutlich mal in teilen zumindest seien
nicht oder na ja der wahnsinn geht ja
von den putin aus und ich kann die
forderung der ukraine verstehen aber es
gibt auch innerhalb der nato darüber
überhaupt gar keinen konflikt wir sagen
wir tun als nato und als mitgliedstaaten
für nato und europäische union was wir
können um der ukraine auch beizustehen
und dazu gehört ausdrücklich auch eine
fortsetzung der militärischen
unterstützung aber wir wollen eben nicht
kriegspartei werden um nicht zum nicht
zu einer wirklichen kriegspartei zu
werden die dann vielleicht auch einen
dritten weltkrieg mit zu verantworten
hat aber das muss man auch unseren
ukrainischen freundinnen und freunden
gut erklären weil ich natürlich schon
auch verstehe dass bei einem bomben
haben mein interesse daran hat dass die
militärischen aggressionen von moskau
ausgehen so gut es irgend geht auch
bekämpft werden damit sie sich schützen
und verteidigen können einer betroffenen
lieferungen haben natürlich die
schlagkraft der militärischen alter der
streitkräfte ukraine erhöht und
verstärkt aber ich warne davor die
illusion zu nähren dass man gegen die
überlegenheit der russischen
streitkräfte mit waffenlieferungen
tatsächlich beikommen kann jeder weiß
von militär die experten sagen alle das
wird keine wende einleiten und dieser
krieg wird nicht zu gewinnen sein was
wir jetzt machen müssen ist sanktionen
und waffenlieferungen werden hier diesen
horror nicht stoppen was diesen horror
stoppen werden sind verhandlungen wir
brauchen verhandlungen wir müssen jetzt
alles tun um diese verhandlungen die ja
zaghaft stattfinden sie zu unterstützen
beispielsweise auch dieses treffen von
selen ski und putin sollte man wirklich
tatkräftig unterstützen dass das
zustande kommt damit es einen
waffenstillstand
bekommt ukraine weil nur ein
waffenstillstand liegt das blutvergießen
beenden keine waffenlieferungen keine
sanktionen die aber ganz kurz mal
zwischen gefragt und so lange bis es
solche gespräche gibt würden sie alles
laufen lassen wollen oder gar inzwischen
schließen lassen
man muss
um zu einer verhandlung bringen was
verstehen sie aber wie ja wie wie jeder
kriegt auch kriege werden durch
verhandlungen beendet nicht durch
waffenlieferungen aber wenn eine seite
nicht verhandeln will was machen sie
dann wieso es wurde doch gesagt sie
wollen verhandeln beide seiten selektion
und politik haben gesagt sie wollen
verhandeln china israel und andere sind
dort schon am vermitteln und das sollte
man unterstützen ich möchte wirklich
davor warnen wenn man
verständlicherweise menschlich
verständlich sagt man möchte mit diesen
adressen nicht verhandeln da muss man
aber auch sagen was man will und es gibt
keine alternative zur verhandlung in
einem krieg aber es müssen ja zwei
seiten zu verhandlungen zustimmen
also verhandlungen und eine weitere
militärische unterstützung schließen
sich ja gar nicht aus sie bedingen
einander die ukraine hat nur eine chance
zu überleben und überhaupt auch putin zu
bewegen zu ernsthaften verhandlungen die
nicht wieder auf lügen und propaganda
beruhen wenn die ukraine stark ist
wehrhaft bleibt und ich höre dieses
argument ja seit drei wochen wir würden
den krieg verlängern also wenn es nach
putin gegangen wäre dann hätte er
innerhalb von 23 tagen die ukraine
überrollt und einer marionettenregierung
eingesetzt aber es ist nicht zuletzt
auch der unterstützung des westens zu
verdanken dass die ukraine noch steht
und dass sie sich tapfer verteidigen
kann und wenn wir das lassen und wenn
wir die ukraine im regen stehen lassen
dann hat putin gewonnen weil er sonst
überhaupt kein interesse daran hätte
sich wirklich auch um ernsthafte
gespräche zu bemühen und es ist im
übrigen auch der ukrainischen seite hoch
anzurechnen dass sie sich immer wieder
an den verhandlungstisch gesetzt hat
gleichwohl putin eine totale
kapitulation eingefordert hat und die
waffe niemals geschwiegen haben
normalerweise ist es so wenn man solche
gespräche führt dann hat man einen
waffenstillstand zumindest zeitlich
befristet aber auch zudem war putin ja
nie bereit das bringt uns aber der
lösung des problems ja keinen schritt
weiter muss ich wirklich sagen jeder tag
an dem dieser krieg nicht gestoppt ist
ist ein tag wo menschen sterben und
hoher blutzoll bezahlt und deshalb als
ich meinen kann ja sein dass man jetzt
menschen beglückwünscht zum heldentum
aber ich möchte keine helden ich möchte
dass dieser krieg beendet wird und dafür
geht es nur mit verhandlungen müssen sie
militär das haben viele gesagt immer
militär gehen kann ein land
einmarschieren und das ist ja jetzt hier
passiert aber die politik die diplomatie
muss jetzt alles tun damit das militär
sich auch zurückziehen da komme
irgendwie nicht so richtig weiter an der
stelle habe ich den eindruck weil ich
sie da auch tatsächlich nicht verstehe
weil dieser krieg wird seitens russlands
gegen die ukraine geführt und nicht und
das ist ja kein wechselseitiges geschäft
was da stattfindet
ich weiß also das ist mal der eine
entscheidende punkt das heißt das könnte
im moment funktioniere noch nur appelle
wenn die eine seite im moment partout
nicht verhandeln will oder auch wie herr
roth eben auch schon ausgeführt hat so
harte vorgaben macht was man erreichen
will wo im moment überhaupt gar keine
verhandlungs potenziell da is a und b es
hat unzählige gespräche gegeben vor
diesem überfall vor dem 24 februar und
auch die haben zu nichts geführt also
das was sie einfordern einen dialog an
meinetwegen auch ein diplomatie hat ja
im vorfeld stattgefunden es hat den
russischen präsidenten offensichtlich
nicht interessiert wir haben jetzt einen
krieg was vorher war ist das eine aber
wenn man nach vorne das problem auflösen
möchte muss man doch folgendes
feststellen wie ist dieser krieg zu
beenden entweder durch eskalation dass
wir einen weltkrieg haben ein inferno
dort wo die nato mit einsteigt was die
ukrainische regierung möchte dass die
nato hier einsteigt oder
wir sagen folgendes und da gibt es ja
wie gesagt signale es gibt doch die
erklärung von herrn präsidentiellen ski
wir wollen verhandeln es gibt die
erklärung von präsident putin wir sind
bereit zu verhandlungen und ich finde
was wir zu tun müssen und sagen so ihr
seid bereit dann bitte schön hier an den
tisch und sie zwingen zu diesen
verhandlungen weil anders können wir
diesen krieg nicht stoppen ich meine was
ist wirklich die alternative zu
verhandlungen da nicht ist die
alternative alternative ist krieg zu
führen und das kann wirklich niemand
niemand der vernunft begabt ist kann
diese eskalation wollen hier ich möchte
nicht dass europa zu einem nuklearen
schlachtfeld wird wo die nato mit in
diesen krieg gegen russland es geht doch
gar nicht wir haben doch eine klare
verabredung getroffen die nato wird
keine kriegspartei werden das ist ja gar
kein streitpunkt zwischen ihrem 90
es gibt eine klare beschlussfassung der
nato und eine klare vereinbarung und von
der sollten wir ausgehen wir sollten
jetzt nicht irgendwelche
nebenkriegsschauplätze eröffnet aber im
kern müssen wir doch mal anerkennen dass
putin sich erst
zaghaft bewegt hat als er gespürt hat
dass er auf massiven widerstand stößt
das heißt nur dann kann es eine
friedliche diplomatische lösung geben
wenn wir die ukraine nicht aufgeben und
diese sehr aggressiven nicht
hinnehmbaren forderungen von putin
gegenüber der ukraine sind ja jetzt erst
von putin leicht relativiert worden weil
er einsehen muss der krieg läuft nicht
so wie er sich das vorgestellt hat und
jeden tag da gebe ich ihnen recht
sterben ja nicht nur ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer sondern auch viele junge russin
die in diesen krieg geschickt werden und
die wahrscheinlich auch überhaupt nicht
wissen warum sie diesen krieg gegen
brüder und schwestern führen sollen denn
das war ja das tat er das war ja das
narrativ von herrn putin aber wir dürfen
doch nicht wieder herrn putin auf den
leim gehen er hat auch gesagt was er
will er akzeptiert nicht die
territoriale integrität
der ukraine er will dass das land
preisgegeben wird und er will das land
im prinzip in die russische
einflusssphäre aufnehmen genauso wie ihr
das faktische mit belarus getan hat und
wenn wir jetzt nicht stehen dann wird
moldau oder irgendein anderes
osteuropäisches land das nächste land
sein was von putin unterdrückt wird was
wichtig ist es dass die ukraine selber
entscheiden sollte über seine zukunft
hat zu ihrem referendum relativ dort ja
und jetzt hat michel rheinische führung
gesagt sie sind zu verhandlungen bereit
diese verhandlungen sollte man
unterstützen und nicht sagen das ist ein
no go das ist no go aus dem westen für
uns ist das bequem von hier zu sagen was
ein no go ist was wichtig ist dass
dieser krieg gestopft wird das leid der
menschen dort beendet wird und dafür ist
es wichtig verhandlungen jetzt zu führen
und ich wünsche mir dass der westen
diese verhandlungen unterstützt wir
könnten dieses gespräch locker noch eine
viertelstunde weiterführen ob wir dann
wo ich noch viel weiter weiß ich
irgendwo moment nicht wer ist da
zumindest noch jede menge punkte
zugesprochen zu sprechen gegeben wie
beispielsweise den die wirkung von
sanktionen und manches mehr wird
sicherlich in der debatte wenn es dann
um die flüchtlinge geht am nachmittag
auch noch mal in der einen oder anderen
form aufkommen für jedenfalls für heute
morgen vielen dank unserer zeit ist
leider schon um dante frau daddeln danke
herr roth dass sie heute morgen bei uns
gewesen sie dürfen jetzt auch sie müssen
auch sogar schon rein gehen denn das ist
eine besondere debatte die hier heute
stattfindet beziehungsweise ist gehört
nicht zur debatte so es ist ein
besonderer tagesordnungspunkt das
ukrainische präsident seelands die hier
live zugeschaltet wird um kurz nach neun
die schau in den plenarsaal sehen katrin
göring eckardt und ich gebe mal ganz fix
rein